- [Gary] There's no C before
the K in my last name.
(audience laughter)
Classic!
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
- Much work
gettin' done in London.
DRock's doing his thing.
I'm focused.
Got a keynote today,
business meetings.
London office, the
VaynerMedia exploding.
Good stuff, rockin'!
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
Some random thought
while I'm in London now.
Just trying to add more content,
context to the vlog.
Just lookin' at
it from Kim Garcia
who runs our Vayner
Experience new division now.
Just completely infatuated
with how the social world
AKA PR'ing yourself to the world
has lead to people doing
a lot of live
events and experiences.
And very excited
about Vayner Experience.
Lotta small businesses here.
A lot of you who are watching,
a lot of big
companies, executives,
should be doing a lot more
in 2017, 2018,
2019 around live events.
Small business senators,
there's a big estate fair
coming up in the summer.
Or a 4th of July extravaganza
that everybody in
your town goes to.
Well you need to
hit up the organizers
and offer them some money
and then you need to
make some sort of setup there
that induces social creative.
So you know, kind of
like creating a background
or setting up
your booth in a spot
that's the best spot.
And then putting like,
take your Instagram photos here.
Buying a Snapchat filter
over to 20,000 square feet
on their ad product.
I think VaynerMedia's ability
to activate experiences,
brands activations
at the Kentucky Derby,
the NFL draft,
you know, Coachella,
is going to end up
becoming a very substantial
part of our
business and our world.
And I definitely think
we're gonna be focusing on
the Budweisers and the Toyotas
and the Chases of the world.
But I definitely think
there a lot of you here
as Vayner itself is
becoming a much bigger player
in small business
with Vayner Beta
and what we're doing there.
I do think that
$10 to $25,000 of risk,
$50,000 of risk
at a big event or a
big regional or local event
for a lot of your
businesses is super important.
And so many of you
have fashion brands
or startup coffees
or breathing stripes
or things of that nature.
And you're trying to do a
lot of influencer marketing
but a nice way to round out
your execution and your branding
is to activate at events.
And so, I think giving out hats
at the Memorial Day
event in your local community
is just good strategy.
Just getting your
product out there.
So experience, real life stuff.
Realizing that people are
hiking, and going to Coachella,
and going to the
fireworks event more today now
because they wanna
post it on their Instagram.
And social media
is a new behavior
that people need to
reconcile and take advantage of.
And I do believe
that most entrepreneurs
don't think of experience
and event marketing.
Especially as
we're in a digital world.
Especially if
you're following me.
I think that
there are arbitrages.
There are
opportunities in all facets
not just which app is next
or what person's about to become
the next big vlogger.
Not not just
Alexa and podcasting
'cause I think
voice is a huge arbitrage.
Literally the two things
that are most on my
mind right now as a marketer
are how I'm gonna
activate against voice,
podcasts and
Alexa and Google Home,
and how I'm going to
activate and take advantage of
people now going to more events,
major and minor,
to promote themselves
and how brands and
businesses can interact in that.
And so, just a little
bit of a different look.
It's a good little rant.
- [DRock] That was great.
- [Gary] Yeah, it was a
bunch of stuff that people--
- [DRock] It's a lot of insight.
- A lot of insight.
That kid motivated
me yesterday in London.
(DRock chuckles) Trying
to get a little deeper.
Ra, ra, ra, ra!
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
Athletes plus TV shows.
How is there no athlete I know
with the last name Orange?
One of these
oranges that... (laughs)
I've got mine.
- [Man] Yeah?
- Yep. Mine is
Jamal Charles in Charge.
- [Man] That's really good.
- Jamal Charles, baby.
That's not bad at all.
- [Man] That's not bad at all.
- Yeah. Feeling pretty good.
- [Man 2] So, are big
companies doomed?
You get to that kind of
innovator's dilemma thing--
- Of course big
companies are doomed.
The good thing
for big companies is
a lot of times
they have an 80 year run
and a lot of people make a
lot of money along the way.
But, sure, what big
company hasn't lost?
- [Man 2] So, I guess, I mean--
- Right? That's a
very important statement.
Like, Woolworth's, IBM,
and IBM's still kicking.
It's not like it's
dead, but Woolworth's isn't.
And, IBM is not
what IBM was in 1979.
Microsoft is not what
Microsoft was in 1992.
You know, Google is not
what Google was in 2001.
Like, why did Google
let Facebook happen?
Like, right?
I mean, I don't
think people get it.
Like, of course
that's what's happens.
Show me.
I don't live in Fantasy Land.
Doesn't happen.
There's not a
single client that does
the work that I want them to do.
- [Man 2] Yet.
- Period.
Because look,
first of all if you're
in client services,
it will never happen.
Like, anybody who cries about
that in client services,
should get out
of client services.
Like, I hate
when people are like,
"Oh, the client doesn't get it.
"This sucks. They're stupid."
I'm like, "You're stupid."
We're reverse engineers.
The problem we solve
for them is their problem.
I don't care if...
Chase is a client of
ours in the U.S., right?
Like, they're huge.
They have a million problems.
And, when I say
problems, the truth is,
and I'm sure you
guys feel this way,
they have a million
opportunities, right?
Do they want people
to open up bank accounts?
Great. There's a
strategy for that.
Do they want to recruit talent?
I mean I would
tell you a lot of people
who are listening right now,
so we have a division
called Vayner Solutions.
It's run by Dog, Dennis OG.
I can't even
pronounce... I'm Russian
and can't
pronounce his last name.
You know, when I think
about the $150,000 audit
that we're
selling because we're not
Bain or McKenzie yet,
and we would normally...
You know, in four
years, we're going to sell...
What I'm about to tell you,
we would sell for $150,000.
A bank listening
would reach out to us
and say, "Hey.
We want you to audit
"our ability to
acquire better talent
"for our bank from a
technology and innovation.
"Not developers, but
marketers and executives
"who have digital
DNA, so that our bank
"can survive this
inevitable death blow
"that, whether
it's cryptocurrency,
"or Apple, and
Google, and Amazon,
"and Facebook's
foray into their world."
This is what's
going to happen to them.
Well, when I think
about the $150,000 package
we play for the audit,
and then the output,
and the advice,
and the presentation,
that is ridiculous ROI.
I also am empathetic to
why they don't see that.
And then, I'm excited
for them to not buy it now,
but buy it for a
million dollars in four years.
But, like that's
something I think a lot
of, like, banks and
B2B companies should
be hiring us for, and
then the video output.
Right? I just think
nobody makes the modern day
commercial better
than my company.
Like, if you want to
spend $300,000 to make
something happen,
I think our $150,000 video
and our $150,000
Facebook ads and
influencers on
Instagram will give you
a better chance than
any Google, or programmatic,
any commercial, any print.
And, so that's
what we strive to do.
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
It's just work.
Like, there's just no shortcuts.
It's a marathon.
You know, like
it's a ton of work.
It's about being right.
I love when people are
like, "Well, you've got
"to be smart, not
just... Right, work hard.
"Oh yeah, Gary, but
you've got to work smart."
I'm like, "No shit, dick."
Like yes, of course you
have to work smart. Next.
The part that people
don't want to do is work hard.
Like, the smart
part is not controllable.
Like, either you're smart
about your strategy or not.
Like, the hard
part is controllable.
Like, you can work
five extra hours a day
instead of watching
TV or going to the pub.
You can work on
the weekends like I did
for every single
year of my twenties.
All of them, every
year of my twenties,
I worked on Saturday for 14
hours in the liquor store.
I don't know.
Nobody in my company
works on Saturday ever.
So like, you know, I
think...Anyway.
- [Man 2] The harder you work,
the luckier you get, right?
- It's an amazing
correlation, isn't it?
Do you know how hard it
is for me to do this vlog?
Ninety percent of
my meetings are talking
about raises, and
clients, and salaries,
and firing, and strategizing
about clients' work.
You know, there's a PR headache
we have with a client right now.
People are mad at me.
I can't speak to it.
I'm legally obligated.
Like, you know.
It's going to happen to you.
The vlog's been
interesting to me.
It is really an
interesting piece of content
because I treat it as something
that I would've made for
the 15-year-old me, right?
Like, I learn by watching.
Like, people are
like, "Gary, you're ..."
Somebody stopped me in the
street yesterday in London.
And, he's like, "Gary, you're
getting too motivational.
I need more details.
Like, you're getting
away from who you are."
I'm like,
"You're getting confused.
This is who I am.
You need to
watch what I'm doing."
I say it a lot, right?
Watch what I'm doing.
Why am I doing this podcast?
You don't have one of the five
biggest podcasts in the world.
All my handlers think this is
the biggest waste
of 30 minutes ever.
This is critiqued as a bad idea.
Now let's break
down why I'm doing it.
I think karma is practical.
I like giving
back to my community.
I think it's ROI positive.
Do I think you
have a million fucking
people listening to this?
No, I do not.
Do I think that 13 people
who have never heard of me
before listen to
this and get on to me?
I sure do.
Do I think in a
15 year window that
that becomes
valuable, my 30 minutes?
Because my 30 minutes are
probably worth $100,000 now.
Um, yeah, I do in 15 years.
Do I think in the
next 15 weeks? I don't.
15 months? Nope.
1.5 years? Probably not.
That's it.
That's how I think
about the world.
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
We're not historians.
We don't look
back to 1955 and say,
"Who was dominating
from 1855 to 1916?"
Like, we don't do that.
We think, "Oh my God,
my company's been around
"for 120 years,
we're not going anywhere."
Because they just
don't do the homework.
I think voice is going to be--
So I would
actually ladder it up.
I would say voice.
I think that podcast ads,
becoming a
podcast, Alexa Skills,
these are all things that
are very top of mind for me.
One thing that
people are misunderstanding
is that time is the only
thing driving our behavior.
Right?
Only thing?
Time is an emerging thing
that is driving our behavior
above and beyond
entertainment escapism,
things of that nature.
- [Woman] Meaning if
you conceive it, you can win.
- Correct.
Meaning when you are driving,
you are not watching a
video, you're just not.
But, you have Bluetooth now,
and your car has Bluetooth,
and instead of the serendipity
of whatever the
local station is playing
or the music that
you've had on your whatever,
you know, it's been
interesting to watch people
shift from music
consumption to information.
Podcasting is big.
Big, big, big,
big, big, big, big.
It's what we're building.
We're just launched a new
division call Vayner Experience.
- [Woman] That's what
they're calling it now
for us too, right,
total brand experience.
- Because we think
activations matter.
Like we are
obsessed with activating.
There's so much
product to be sold
when the rugby world
championship was here.
But every brand
paid a sponsorship,
had some cocamanian booth
outside of Wembley Stadium,
and called it a day.
I'm fascinated by how much money
brands are
wasting on activations.
Without making social content
created by people in the batter.
Everybody's making the cupcake,
and then at the end going,
"Oh, let's do a hashtag,
"like on the sign,
"and people will put that,"
and nobody gives a fuck.
When an
influencer takes a picture,
when a person takes a
picture of your product,
without you knowing,
like it happens everyday.
- [Woman 2] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You guys aren't in
control of the narrative.
People are seeing
it in different lights.
Some retailers put you
on an end cap at $3.99,
others put you on
a pedestal for $4.19.
You guys are not in control,
but you think you are,
and you're justifying
that marketing talk
because that's how
everybody was taught marketing
40 fucking years ago.
It's ludicrous.
Everybody's
interpreting differently.
Louis Vuitton,
go ahead, write it down,
write down right now two
sentences on Louis Vuitton.
Knock yourselves out.
Let's see how fucking
aligned this actually is.
This is what
marketers think is happening.
It's not real.
What does that mean?
It's schizophrenic?
It's not schizophrenic at all.
I know I have to go,
(women laugh)
it's the reality of
what is actually happening.
So yeah, that's what I think.
- Dan.
- Dan? How are you? Gary.
- Really good, thank you man.
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you? Such a pleasure.
- Hiya, man.
- You good?
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
- Hey, how are you?
- 60 plus online entrepreneurs.
- I love it, I love it.
- [Woman 3] Thank you
so much, Gary,
- You're welcome, guys.
You're welcome, thank you.
- Hello, here we are.
- Oh, we're on video.
Live.
- We are live at the
ILEC Conference Center,
and yes finally.
- Yes.
- The moment we've
all been waiting for.
The incomparable, GaryVee.
- Thanks you
- So are you excited?
- No. No, I'm just kidding.
Super excited,
always ready to go.
- So I just want
to thank you again,
for making the trip.
- Thank you.
I'm thrilled to be here.
- I know it's going
to be short and sweet.
- Yes, heading home tonight.
But super focused,
gonna get my shit together
and I'm gonna drill it on
stage in a couple minutes.
- Drill it.
- Awesome, thank you.
Good to see you.
I'll see you up there.
Hey guys, hello.
- [Man 3] GaryVee! Whoo!
- It's my wife's
birthday tomorrow.
You gotta wrap
your head around it.
Realizing how fortunate you are,
and how life is only one at-bat,
and how great it is.
You gotta jam,
one step at a time.
One step at a time,
To me, the advice,
that I believe in
is that the hard
work and the efforts
are the most controllable thing.
So you need to keep grinding,
and if they aren't happening
the way you want them to,
you gotta stay patient.
There's just no other option.
So I think patience, hard
work, and just perspective
of reminding yourself
why you're doing it.
- [Gary] How have you been?
- Good!
- Good.
- Hello. Christian.
- [Gary] Christian,
pleasure to meet you.
- You too.
- Yeah.
Hey brother,
good to see you again.
- Good to see you.
- How you doing?
- There's quite a bit
of people waiting for you.
- Yes. Is it crazy?
- It's crazy.
- Fill my audience,
they all know the
importance of personal branding.
But if you had to
do just one thing,
one sort of concerted effort,
building a personal brand.
You can only do one thing,
whether that's sort
of Instagram, et cetera,
what would that one thing be?
- Daily vlog.
- [Man 4] And
documenting yourself?
- Hundred percent.
And not painting
a fake narrative.
So if you're on the--
like, the biggest
problem that people make,
or mistake,
excuse me not problem,
that people make when they're
building a personal brand
is they want to fake it
before they make it.
They want to say they're this
or they start a vlog
and they start doing shit
that they never--
Like my vlog's boring as fuck!
Like it's a spin,
like I've done--
What are we at DRock? 250?
- [DRock] No, it's more like--
- Whatever.
I've done 200 episodes plus
and like 84% of them
have similarities, right.
Like I think that if
you're gonna document
versus creating,
then you've got to
document your truth.
So if you're just like a bro
in the basement of your house
trying to become
an eSports celebrity
and you kinda suck at Call
of Duty or League of Legends,
just fuckin' document it.
Like document going to
7-11 and buying Doritos.
Like document like taking
the cab to the fucking grocery.
Like, people are genuinely,
so I think people think they're
trying to paint a documentary
or be on Shark Tank,
meanwhile, what
they should be doing
is doing a reality show.
Like, and if you're
just truly yourself,
you have a much
better chance of success
because the only thing
that is unique or, you know,
like it's very cliche,
like "You're like
a fuckin' snowflake",
but the truth is that's true.
- [Man 4] And if
someone's life is--
- Boring?
- [Man 4] Boring.
- Yeah.
- [Man 4] Do
they still document?
- Yes.
- [Man 4] Yeah?
- But then what they
have to understand is
if they're boring,
and not smart,
and not interesting,
and not funny,
and not attractive,
nobody's gonna watch.
Like, you've got
to have something!
Like,
why do you think
people break out?
Like, it is talent.
But if you're not documenting,
like look,
there's an
unlimited amount of people
that can win on vlogging
and on Instagram because
they're just fucking hot.
They may not be
that interesting,
but if you're
building more exposure,
you're a model.
Some people are comedians,
some people
are business legends.
You know, some people are
gonna be what they're gonna be.
So I think that
documenting makes sense.
Because the other thing is,
if you're not documenting,
as a personal brand,
you're pondering,
you're overthinking.
It's about production,
it's about putting it out there.
What's very different
than the old TV world,
the old music world
that we all grew up with,
is I think people
overthink their content.
There's too much supply and
demand issues with content.
You can never, you know,
feed the audience too much
because they're not consuming
every little thing you're doing.
And if they are,
and I have that,
I have a personality where
people get in the rabbit hole
and they're there for a while
and then they kick out!
And then they kick back in.
It's no different than when
you're really into an artist.
You're all about fuckin'
Lady Gaga for like a year
and then you're
not for a year or two
and then if Gaga's good enough
and her next
album's good, right?
I'm a big believer that you
just build the biggest building
by building the
biggest building.
I don't spend any time tearing
down people's buildings.
The biggest reason
I don't talk a lot about
the bad part of entrepreneurship
is I don't want people
to get the misperception
that I'm like
"I'm an entrepreneur!
"You're not!".
That is not what I'm saying!
I'm saying if you are depressed,
if you're like sad,
if you're going into debt,
there's people like going
into hundred thousand dollars
in credit card debt
to start their company
and they've never sold
anything in their lives
'cause they want
to put entrepreneur
on a fuckin' Instagram profile!
Like, that scares me!
Like that's gonna
have ramifications!
But yeah, you're right,
I mean, it's
everybody's different.
I love eating shit,
I love the process,
I'm only about the journey.
I even think subconsciously
I leave a lot of
money on the table
'cause I'm trying to
foreplay the outcome.
Like I think it's so locked in
that I'm trying
to like delay it!
'Cause I love it so much!
You know, so
everybody's different.
Everybody wants stuff.
I don't want stuff.
I don't want a yacht,
I don't want a watch,
I don't want a jet.
I want the New York Jets.
- The Jets.
(group laughter)
- But that's about it
and honestly, even that,
I would far prefer.
If you told me,
if I could have it my way,
would I take the Jets at 64
or would I take the Jets at 46?
I would take it at 64.
I want the grind,
I want the narrative,
I want the legacy,
I want the documentation
of it.
Because I know it's
gonna be way more powerful
when I have
27 years of vlogs
of showing how I got there.
Because that's not
seeing just Instagram!
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- So when kid
rolls up to me at 62
and goes "Uh duh duh",
I'll be like "Go watch
"DailyVee.
"1 to 14,086!
Then!"
Right? 'Cause that's--
- No, I get it--
- That's your point!
That's what's so great
about this body of work.
I'm gonna have
something, you know?
I wish people--
I've started putting
up some older content.
I put up a piece on
Instagram yesterday from 2008
saying the same shit!
It's fuckin' 10 years later!
I've been doin'
this for a long time.
This was, everyone's like "GaryVee!"
Like, obviously I've
had some real viral growth
in my personal brand
in the last six months.
It's definitely
taken a different leap.
But people are like,
"Oh, you're, you know,
"you blew up overnight!"
I'm like, "Fuck me!"
I'm like, "Really?"
- I'm an 18-year-old
entrepreneur.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I am, I started a business.
What question,
and I know I'm
meeting you today,
what question
should I be asking you?
- That's a great
question actually.
So, I'm gonna answer
that slightly different.
I'm gonna answer it
with anything that allows
me to say something
that makes you realize
don't give a fuck about
anything for the next 18 years.
If I could convince every
18-year-old entrepreneur
to shut down the emotional
needs for short-term shit
until they're 36,
they will all be successful.
Let me tell you a secret.
This is a little secret.
The majority of entrepreneurs
that you look up to,
shit on you behind your back!
Because they can see the
short-term bullshit behavior.
The biggest thing
I tell a lot of kids
I fall in love with emotionally,
I'm like, "Bro, you
might be tricking 93%,
"but the 7% that rule the world,
"think you're a clown."
And that is the energy that I
want to give the 18-year-old.
How much time you have
and when you're
doing short-term shit,
and faking the funk,
and raising capital,
and not actually
building a business,
or playing the part,
or just going to parties,
or renting a yacht
when you don't have it
to play the part.
You're tricking 93%
and it feels real good.
The problem is the 7%
that are gonna matter,
think you've
already lost with them.
There's a lot of
people that I've crossed out
that everybody
thinks is super cool
and they're not
gonna be here in six years.
'Cause I've been
through this before.
- [Man 4] Cool.
- Cool.
- [Man 4] Thank you so much!
- You got it!
- We really appreciate it.
- Awesome, my pleasure.
(laughter)
That was some good stuff!
- [Man 4] Yeah,
I thought it was good too.
("Cobvlt Blues" by DEADCVPRI)
- You know, listen,
I think you win
when you fucking fall
in love with patience and
you love the fucking grind.
- I'm Matthew.
- Matthew, Gary, how are you?
- Nice to meet you,
nice to meet you.
- Hi Gary, I'm Roland,
- Roland, real pleasure, Gary.
- [Richard] I'm Richard.
- Richard, such a pleasure.
Hey, good to see you again.
- Sanjay.
- Sanjay, good to see
you again, yes outside.
- We met only
about 15 minutes ago.
- Hi, I'm Lucy.
- Lucy, such a pleasure.
- Lovely to meet you Gary.
- Gary, James.
- James, such a pleasure.
("Cobvlt Blues" by DEADCVPRI)
I'll tell you what you should
do, you should partner with
somebody who's a
financial based
individual, a CFO.
And have her or him help you
justify the savings of money,
and sell only on that.
You might be able to sell me,
but the problem with me is
we're already kind of doing it
in a weird way with
our Chief Heart Officer.
Like I'm already sold.
Then you've got 99.3%
of the rest of the market,
who don't give a fuck.
They're companies.
But if you walk in and say,
you will save
$1.9 million
and you have it not the way
you and I intuitively know,
but you have it in data.
- [Lucy] Fact, yeah.
- You will sell a shit load.
- [Lucy] Beautiful.
- Got it?
- [Lucy] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Cool.
The biggest
thing with that model,
that I'm fearful
of is normally the ROI
of the cost doesn't match
the quality of the content.
And so I think as long
as you deliver on that,
then you've got
something very real.
The problem is the
math gets too good,
and the person
allows it to dilute.
There's been a lot of people
who've started mastermind
and scaled advice
businesses that started
with the right intent
and then got fucked.
In the best way
possible for them,
because they
made a lot more money.
I think the only piece of
advice I would give you, my man,
is there's a very fine line
between being great and
being completely full of shit,
and spammy in this model.
Which is why I don't do it.
'Cause I don't
think I can control it,
'cause I think
I'm too charismatic
and good of a salesman,
that it would be so big,
that I would fuck it up so bad.
And I would be cliche
of what I make fun of.
I would just tell
you this is a difficult,
by the way, this is why
I'm giving you this advice,
it's a foregone conclusion
to me that you'll be okay
and it's gonna work.
So that's not the
advice I'm giving you.
The advice I'm giving you is
if you care about your legacy,
you need to be very smart
that you don't get seduced
by the model.
And all of a sudden
people are paying a lot
of money for getting nothing.
Or something they
can get online for free.
Which is why I spend
my time writing books,
and speaking, and
building an agency,
because once you
make it about you,
to make it big you
gotta make it shitty.
(chuckling)
Yeah, it's a, you know
I've never said it that way.
So that made a lot a
sense to everybody here, right?
That's what happens.
The thing that
you always want to do,
is you want to win with winners.
And a lot of these
models win with losers.
So, you know, you
wanna win with winners.
Something to think about.
My big thing is you just
gotta feel good about it.
And if you don't, and you're
asking me because of that?
Well then bring
in a little back.
You don't need to
build the biggest business.
Gotta feel good about
how you make your money,
and if you don't
you're vulnerable.
You're vulnerable to yourself,
and you're
vulnerable to the market.
- [Roland] Thanks very much.
- Yeah, no problem.
I mean I could make
$100 million a year being me
in this model.
I don't want to
because I don't like the idea
of I can't
screen who's taking it.
Like to me it's back to
this winners, losers thing.
The model attracts the wrong
moths in it's worst form.
When I say
document and don't create,
when I say act
like a media company,
when I say the
most important one,
watch what I'm doing
verse what I'm saying.
Even think about
what happening here.
I'm synthesizing it for you,
but it's the what I'm
doing versus what I'm saying.
This is it man.
- [Richard] Okay.
- You can build a huge fan base.
You can literally film shit,
make an episode everyday,
put it on Facebook, run $500
worth of ads against your fans,
and fucking own it.
Because I may fall in love
with the groundskeeper guy,
and she may fall in love with
the really cute midfielder,
and he may
really like the coach.
(group laughter)
You know, right?
- [Richard] Yes,
perfect, perfect.
- That will work.
You should let them
put out a song everyday
on SoundCloud and Spotify.
- Everyday, what about
the quality of the song?
'Cause you know
that's what they like.
- [Gary] Yeah,
and you're so excited.
Who likes, the
fans or the writers?
- [Richard] No, the artists.
You know, they can be hard work.
They're like okay
I got to get this right.
- They're wrong.
Their quality is
subjective to their own mind.
It's why they're artists.
- [Richard] Exactly, yeah, yeah.
Well I knew that,
but, okay, so--
- You have nothing else, right?
There's no way to win in music,
without putting
out volumes of music.
- [Richard] So put
it on SoundCloud free?
- Yep, and
Spotify free, and then,
(holding breath)
(group laughter)
And that's a joke, but the
reality is if they're good,
I think it's a volume game.
- [Richard] Yeah.
And I think it
they're good enough,
that one song
could change everything.
Look, I think, you know,
DRock can send you this.
So I can say to them,
look you can't have your cake
and eat it too.
- [Richard] Yeah.
- Like, if you want to be fancy
and subjective about your music,
and not put it out?
Well then your gonna
have less chances of winning.
So like what do you want?
I have good news, why don't
you put out a song everyday
for three years, and
then if one of them hits?
Then you can afford to
not put one out everyday.
- [Richard] Yeah,
no I get it, yeah.
- I mean I think
artists want their shit
to get out to the world.
I think that they're insecure.
But what they don't
realize it's all subjective.
It's just subjective.
Like, I don't know, like I vlog,
and there's
something I said in here,
and they'll edit it.
And I don't tell
them what to fucking edit.
And maybe it's good, maybe
it's bad, and I don't know.
Everyday people are like,
the best thing you've ever said.
And I'm like, really?
Fucking that's shit.
Or I'm like, you
know, the next day,
why didn't that video crush?
That's the smartest
shit I've ever said.
I've written four books.
The best book I've wrote is
called, "Thank You Economy."
It's the least selling by far.
- [Matthew] Yeah, it's
an awesome book, love it.
- Thank you, you
know what I mean?
- [Matthew] Yeah.
- So you know.
- It's just awareness.
And the way you get
awareness is running ads
on underpriced places,
or siphoning awareness
from underpriced places.
There's two places,
Facebook Ads and influencers.
Like I am a
broken fucking record.
DRock, what episode
into the vlog did you say,
how are we going to create
something interesting everyday.
- [DRock] I think like three.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] It's true, it's true.
Episode three,
episode three, DRock goes,
you know I don't see this--
- [DRock] I don't
know if I went that far.
- The vibe was
you were concerned.
You were like how is this
going to be, like, interesting?
- [DRock] Yeah, when are we
going to jump out of a plane,
or you know.
(group laughter)
- That's what you
were thinking, right?
- [DRock] Yeah, like what
are we going to do visually,
to like make it--
- And he's always
saying things like, look,
if we made this eight
seconds instead of 30, or this.
And he's right, he's right,
the data shows he's right,
but I'm trying to
prove a macro-point.
You know how much fun
this is going to be for me?
'Cause I'm doing this everyday
for the rest of my life.
You know how much fun
this is going to be for me
in 20 years, when
I get to tell a kid,
go watch all 7,000 episodes
of DailyVee to understand.
You know how pissed
I am I don't have this
for the last 20
years of my life?
Do you know how weird
episode one, through 10 years,
through episode
3,600 would have been
of everyday being
at the liquor store?
Do you know how much
more impactful that would be?
It's one thing
when I say it, right?
Notice how I'm even
saying it in detail,
how more impactful it is.
Imagine seeing it,
imagine literally, literally,
as you got in to me, were like,
let me go look at DailyVee.
So wait that was
Monday, that was, like,
liquor store, liquor store,
liquor store, liquor store.
- [DRock] Like Wine Library TV
for 1,000 episodes--
- Yeah, it's there.
- [DRock] And it's just
me sitting there drinking.
(group laughter)
- Well from 2006 to
2011, 200 episodes a year,
250 episodes, I did
1,000 episodes in five years.
Like 200 plus episodes
a year, five days a week.
Boom, boom.
Would I make those videos once
in a while that you
guys never want to make.
Which is 11 minutes
of every episode
of Wine Library TV
just flashing.
They're like, no,
it's not gonna do well.
I know it's not gonna do well.
I'm just making a point.
- But is there gonna be any--
- [Man 5] We've got a
security issue downstairs.
I need to get you
into the room as quickly.
- [Gary] Where we going?
- [Man 6] We are
going over here.
- [Gary] Hey guys.
Good, how are you?
- [Man 7] Hey, Gary.
- [Gary] Hey guys.
What's up guys?
How are ya?
Nice shirt, bro.
Hey guys.
How are ya?
- [Man 8] Hey, Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Man 9] Good, thanks.
(inaudible people
chatting with one another)
- [Gary] Alright,
where am I going?
(people cheering and chatting)
- [Woman 3] I love you, Gary.
- [Gary] I love you back.
What's up, buddy?
What's up my man?
- [Man 9] I had a
meeting with a man who changed
my fucking life and
called me on my bullshit
and made me put
this event together.
(people cheering and screaming)
- [Gary] There's no C
before the K in my last name.
(audience laughter)
Classic.
Here's what I think.
I think that
information is commoditized.
There's so much
information on the internet.
It's hard to sell
information, in my opinion,
and feel good about it
because there's so much of it.
There's a reason
my content is free.
It's because the
supply and demand of content
is harder than ever
to sell and differentiate
if you want to
feel great about it
because there's so much content.
Is your $300 thing
actually available for
four hours of Google searching?
Is your $100 thing actually
available for $9?
Answer's yes.
I'll save you
time as you debate it.
You know zero
people, zero people,
that actually created wealth.
I don't mean your lucky friend
who inherited his
grandmother's money.
I mean you don't
know anybody on Earth
that created an actual
business and made wealth
without working
their fucking face off.
There is no such
thing as passive income.
It doesn't exist.
You might have something that's
working for a little while
because you did
landing page optimization
and you figured out
how to arbitrage Google
for a few seconds,
aka a couple years,
but that will go away when
Google changes its algorithm
or when people
go to mobile devices
or when Facebook
becomes more important.
Which means it was
working for 24 months or 16
but now it's not which
is everything but passive
because you start
building your life on it
and then when shit hits the fan,
you have to adjust and
it really fucks you up.
So, these are the big
things that I think about.
Which is,
why are so many
people looking for shortcuts
when life is long?
Why are people not willing to
do the tried and true thing
when if you just
audit every single situation
it's always the same thing.
Which is the people
that run marathons win
and the people that
are running sprints lose.
And it's because
people lack patience.
People are seduced by stuff.
People make all
their decisions on
short term money
because they want stuff.
People are
insecured and want to posture
in front of other
people that they're successful.
There's just a million
fucking reasons why you do it
but it just
doesn't make it right.
So, I'm on a
little bit of a mission.
You know, my big thing is,
I build other businesses
and then the GaryVee
stuff is kind of like out there
and does its thing.
Sure, it leads to
opportunities, but for me,
I'm on a mission
for legacy around this.
I'm not, you know, I'll
get paid to come and speak.
I'll write my books, but I'm
not trying to create content
as a top of the funnel thing
to sell something at scale.
I'm not against that.
I know the far majority
of people want to do that.
Mazel Tov.
Knock yourself out.
It's just not the way I see it
because I don't think
that's how the trends play out.
And if you're good
enough, you don't need it.
So these are
things that keep playing
over and over in my mind.
Over and over in my mind.
Stakes are high.
Opportunities very high.
The competition is real.
Every single person in this room
is competing with each other
no matter how they position,
or slighten position,
because we're going
into an attention battle.
We only have so much attention.
Time is the asset.
I want you to understand
why I do the things I do
because I know that
the tactics I've laid out
over and over and
over and over again,
you guys can verbatim,
repeat some of my shit,
it's you need
to understand why.
The only thing that
will ever have value
is if you understand
people and you try to
desperately figure
out how to provide them
more value than you're
asking from them in return.
And that is where
almost everybody breaks.
Everybody is selfish.
You want the money.
You want the thing.
You don't want to
provide more value
than that thing is worth.
You actually want
to do it the other way.
And by the way, when I say you,
I'm not talking about this room,
I'm just talking about
the whole fucking game.
Everybody.
It's why so few
people break through.
Because when
everybody's doing the same shit,
they don't win.
And all these systems
look the fucking same.
And they all do the same
thing and it forces everybody
into the same behavior
and then there's a reason why
a few people break through,
because they go the other way.
Everybody goes left,
couple people go right.
That's where all
the fucking action is.
All the action is in one place.
In a world where
everybody is creating content
for the internet which is
where everybody's eyes are,
over and over,
only a few can break through
because they're providing
more value in return
and they have patience
to not ask for
money in the upfront
but they
actually build something
and then they're able
to extract value later.
And I just, I don't
know, I'm worried that
everybody's getting pushed
into things that they're not
instead of blocking it out and
going all in on who they are.
'Cause that's just
where it's gonna be.
That's just tried and true.
I want to get ready for Q&amp;A's
so let's get the mics going.
If you've got a question,
start putting up your hands.
Let's definitely go with that
little girl who went first.
(audience applause)
(little girl speaking)
- Hold on, hold on, hold on.
What's your name little girl?
- My name is Tegan, hello.
I love you so much,
you're awesome.
(audience laughter)
- [Gary] Thank you!
- And I've got
some gifts for you.
- [Gary] Well I'd like them.
Do you wanna come up
here and give them to me?
(audience applause)
How are you?
Thank you.
Can I have a hug?
Alright.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
You've written three books?
Jesus fucking Christ!
(audience laughter)
That's amazing!
(audience applause)
Great job!
- My business right now
or the thing that
I'm doing on Instagram
it's starting to become
like Destroyer Photography
in this sort of way.
I take good pictures.
But I want to send a
message to other artists
about thinking that art
isn't what it used to be.
Like you cannot make
money or a living out of it.
You should actually try to be
more of a personality around it.
So my question is how
would you market this idea?
- So you wanna be somebody
that tells other artists
that's not
about selling the art,
it's that you need to
build a personal brand
and be the
personality behind the art
and then that's the monetization
'cause then
people will buy your art?
Or because then you
can do something else?
- [Man 11] Exactly,
the second part.
I don't know, I shouldn't like,
pursuing art for
the sake of doing art
and monetizing if you wanted
but if you want
to do something else.
- I mean first, I would not
tell them how to monetize.
So the biggest
artists in the world
are self promoters and
marketers of their brand
and then they sell the art.
So the first one to me,
is a far more
interesting conversation
because artists are
artists for a reason.
There's a
reason all those people
wanna take those photos
or paint those pictures.
It's 'cause it's
what they're good at
or they like or
it's what they love.
So forcing them
into like, "Forget that.
"The art is the
gateway to for you
"to be a personal
brand and monetize that,"
I think is bad strategy, right?
You just have
entrepreneurial DNA in you
that happened to
match along with the art
and that's
actually a rarity, right?
Most people don't carry both.
This is what I'm, to be
very frank, concerned of.
The thought that the model is,
let's take them out
from what they wanna do
or what they wanna be doing
and I'm gonna teach them how
to build a personal brand.
The first question becomes
why are you the
right person to do that?
Like, have you done that?
- [Man 11] Yeah, I'm doing it
like day to day since January
that I came up with the concept.
- Doing what?
- [Man 11] Doing what,
what do you mean?
- Have you made
money not being the artist
but you're making money
using art as the gateway?
- [Man 11] Yeah, the
second part at least.
- How, how are you making money?
- [Man 11] I started
by taking the pictures
and selling them.
- Okay.
- [Man 11] And
so what I've done is
taken your advice of
narrating my reality day to day.
- You're vlog, right?
- [Man 11] Right now,
I'm not making a
living out of doing this
I'm just building
like the vlogs to get there
because of maybe
to get it started.
- No it's okay,
it's a good strategy.
Here's the problem.
Too many people want
to go into teaching people
how to make
money a different way
before they've
actually ever made money
without making money teaching
people how to make money.
(audience applause)
I mean, for me,
what gave me the audacity
to talk about
business was in my 20s,
for 12 years without saying
a fuckin' word to anybody,
I built a $60 million
retail business.
That made me feel like,
oh let me tell you what I did
or what I thought about.
So I think the big
thing that concerns me
is I think vlogging and building
awareness and documenting,
that's good.
'Cause that's gonna
bring you attention.
My friends, attention is
the currency of our society.
The number one
arbitrage in our world,
it's called fame, right?
Get real famous and
the weirdest shit happens,
people give you
everything for free.
Makes no sense, it's backwards.
It's the number one arbitrage.
So getting people to
care about you for you
and your journey is important.
What you do with that
power and how you make money
is even more important.
That's the thing to think about.
So I would say,
before you tell people
how to make money about it,
you need to do
that for yourself first.
Figure out what
that was and then do it.
- [Man 11] Okay,
thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
- [Man 12] What should you do
when your heads telling you
that you know (muffled speech)
the rest is gonna come then.
But you're heart's
pulling you in a different path?
- [Gary] Can you do both?
'Cause I push a lot
of people to do both.
When I hear that,
I'm like fuck, man.
Just do me a huge favor and
audit every other hour, right?
Like, that's a tough one, right?
When the head and
heart are aligned, magic!
When the head and heart are
pulling in opposite directions,
back to why I was
scared with artists, right?
They're not gonna be aligned.
That sucks comma,
I need to know everything you do
every hour you're awake
because if I can
audit it carefully,
I think you might be doing
enough dumb shit
that doesn't matter
that will let you do both.
Like, you know?
(audience applause)
It's a very
interesting thing, right?
Like, how many
hours, by the way,
I sleep six to
seven hours a night
and I think it's always
funny that people think,
like yeah, I only
sleep three hours.
Like sleep is a non-debate,
like you need it.
So but I'm
asking this carefully.
How many hours a
night do you tend to sleep?
Tell the truth, do not lie.
- [Man 12] No, no, eight.
- [Gary] Good, sleep seven.
Like, one less hour, right?
You just told me
very passionately
that your head and your heart
are pulling in
opposite directions.
That's worth seven versus eight!
Comma, how much
telly do you watch?
How many beers do you drink?
How many YouTube
videos do you watch?
How many fuckin'
conferences do you come to?
(audience laughter)
Here's what I know.
I believe that you
have enough time to do both.
Especially if any of 'em
has anything to
do with the internet.
Guys, every one of our
grandparents didn't have this.
If they had a job and they
wanted to build
another business,
that means that
they needed to be there!
They didn't have
the fuckin' internet.
We're so lucky!
Let's take advantage of it.
We're the first generation,
no matter what our age is,
that's living
through this internet thing
that's bonkers shit crazy good.
That's worth chipping away.
You should sit down right now,
not listen to a word I'm saying
and write down
every fuckin' thing you do
seven days a week.
You've got family, you know.
You've got things,
people have things.
But you have
enough time for both.
- [Man 12] You're right.
- [Gary] If you want it.
(audience applause)
("Cobvlt Blues" by DEADCVPRI)
Going home.
Just wanted to thank
everybody for watching the vlog.
Means so much to me.
Obviously this is
from Friday in London.
It's Sunday afternoon right now.
Getting ready for the week.
Super focused, super revved up
Ready to do some serious damage.
A lot going on.
So much opportunity.
It's a mindset thing.
Either you're excited
about it or you're not.
I'm ridiculously
excited about it
and I see all the
opportunities at hand.
Practitionership.
Architecture.
Optimism.
("Cobvlt Blues" by DEADCVPRI)